[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 58 of
the weekly google apart from podcast I
am Francis Campo and I'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark how are
you doing I'm very sleepy you got me up
very early this morning because you're
in Europe i know i'm i mean this
beautiful place called tareas de I got
near Barcelona way home and yeah it it's
like 420 p.m. here so I was like 7am in
some Francis yeah it's like yeah you got
me up get me up super early yeah thanks
for that I love you thank you so much
I'm not even sorry yeah I'm actually I'm
actually not even sorry about that i'm
sorry about the topic of the podcast
today you're not sorry I mean so today's
topic is where France esque
spontaneously combusts cuz we're talking
about Java yeah but we have a wonderful
conversation about Java and Java on gcp
with racing and receive dial yep you may
you may recognize ray from previous
episodes as well yep such as many others
actually I think that he did one with
the one I can remember is the one about
Google Cloud spin yeah I could go classf
in that was fun but I think he's also
been to another one I don't remember now
that's all right and then at the end
we're gonna have a discussion about
moving data between cloud providers
specifically if you need to move data
from s3 to cloud storage is there an
easy way to do that but before we do
that why don't we get stuck into our
cool things of the week francisca I know
you found a bunch of really interesting
ones yeah there's one there's actually
two of them that I'm very excited about
because there are things that I'm
actually gonna do the first one is a
tensorflow course it's a crash course on
the eloni with tensorflow it's three
hours long and it doesn't require phc
that's what they say so I'm pretty
excited because i do not have one so I
do not have a PhD either yes I'm very
excited about going through learning a
little bit more about all the t's they
also tends to flow and how to actually
use it for something specific like try
to build something with it I've been
thinking about it for a while
anything that that that's a perfect
opportunity to try yeah it looks like
it's a video course is that right yeah
it's actually a video course it's as I
said a bunch of hours but but it's
definitely worth it it's done by Martin
gonna one of our teammates developer
advocate for Okla platform in parts very
very cool so speaking of teammates one
of our other developer advocate
teammates Amy or Amidala issues on
twitter has written a blog post about
combining cloud ml natural language api
and running a slack bot and how they can
be integrated together yeah it is it is
really cool but because this two things
I mean there's this but and everybody
likes pots of course but also there is
over part about cloud ml the natural
language api is super powerful i don't
know if you've played a little bit with
it a little bit a little bit yeah one of
my favorite things is that you can it
does entity recognition which is
basically you can say things like new
york and it's exactly a new york but you
can also say the big apple and it will
say yeah new york so it's actually able
to understand all these complex concepts
and tie them together which is very nice
yeah what i thought was quite
interesting about this too so it does
cinnamon analysis in terms of like are
these positive comments or negative
comments and can respond but you can
also do like topped entity listings so
you can start to see what the topics of
conversation across time have been
within the slack channel which i think
is actually really really cool yeah yeah
i will now get into the details on the
slack channel where she's talking cuz it
seems like it's related to politics
which i tried to avoid lately anyway i
think we have one more cool thing of the
week though yeah so we talked about this
a little bit last week where we're
talking about cloud audit logging so
that you can determine like who does
what and where and when and how on the
Google cloud platform around but
literally last week when we announced
the blog at the same time I so it
renounce the podcast at the same time
there was a blog put out explaining that
we have significantly expanded set of
products that cloud audit logging is now
integrated with which is really cool so
it's now works with compute engine
container engine data proc
cloud DNS key management service cloud
storage and cloud sequel people have
integrations are all in beta but it does
work across the board so it's pretty
sweet and the article goes through how
you can interact with the audit logs in
cloud console how you can interact with
them in stackdriver you can do alerts
and it even talks about if you're signed
up for the offer for cloud functions how
you can also use cloud functions to
interact with your audit trails as well
so you can have automatic responses to
certain actions that people take within
your Google cloud platform project which
i think is pretty cool as well nice so
yeah I think that is important to
remember to remind our tour listeners
just in case you were wondering like
what is the difference between cloud
other logging and Google Cloud I am
because sometimes there may be a little
bit confusing the way I like to put it
is cloud I am says who is allowed to say
to do what and plot audit locking says
who did what so it's not if you're alas
not is like did you actually do it so
it's good for logging like if you have
something that people are allowed to do
but you want to make sure that they
don't do it too often or do they have a
reason behind it to do it that is the
product to use mm-hmm sounds good all
right well I think that's probably
enough for cool things of the week I'm
sure we could go on for a while but why
don't we go have a chat with Ray and
receive and talk about Java I don't want
it not to get led to that it sounds good
today we are joined by a teammate and
also by an engineering manager we are
joined today by right sang and received
al uh ray how are you doing today pretty
good how are you good and Rajiv how are
you doing I'm well I'm well thank you
for asking excellent excellent so before
we get stuck into all the good things
why don't you tell us a little bit about
yourself Rajiv why don't you go first so
I'm receive and I'm an engineering
manager here at google I've been at
Google for about 10 years or so so quite
a while and I'm right now managing teams
to work on the cloud SDK and Java on
Google's cloud platform so I'm really
focused on cloud developer
tools before that I used to work on the
Google web toolkit or org wit as it's
now called so yeah some of you may
remember that I remember that I used to
use that long time I go yeah let's go
what about you right whether you tell us
a little bit about what do you do sure
so I'm a developer advocate I'm based in
New York and I focus a lot on the Java
communities and Java developers in
making sure that the experiences with
Google cloud platform is the best for
the community as well and if I'm not
mistaken it's your second episode with
us that's right yes this is my second
episode thanks for having me back given
that the last last episode on how well
we did I'm sorry I was all oh thank you
yeah but it was the it was the clouds
being episode which I had a lot of fun
with so I'm happy to be back again
awesome we're very happy that you're
back excellent alright so we are having
an episode about Java we have talked
about some other languages so figured
it's good to come around a Java as well
um so I guess I'll astra g if you know
like why java why is javor important to
gcp what's the what's the story there
well um java you know it's an important
language it's been it's been I guess it
was really like mid 90s and then since
then it just become you know pretty much
a staple language that's used that's
used everywhere honestly it's used very
heavily an enterprise I think the
language index the tob index still shows
Java as the most used most heavily used
language across the board for all sorts
of applications so yeah it's just a you
know it's a it's a hugely important
language and it's also um you know I
think one of the reasons for that is
because it's just pretty versatile as
well like it's it's one of those
languages some people say like oh you
know which is more expressive or it's
too verbose when some of those things
may be true but it's also shown that you
can build like really large applications
and services with it like you can have
like really big code bases and they're
still maintainable so yeah it's a so
it's really important that you know we
support java developers and such
workloads on gcp especially as more
enterprises are
the cloud also I know that one of the
like one of the places where we talk
about job all the time on the cloud is
App Engine but what what what are the
things are there in Google cloud
platform that are related to Java and
the what is the best places to run Java
google cloud platform um that's a so
I'll take I'll take a stab at this and
then break jumpin um I think it depends
on what you're doing right so App Engine
app engine standard actually is is like
a good place to run job if you really
care about like very like sort of spiky
traffic very fast sort of like scale up
and scale down you want to have reactive
pneus to that and you're okay with sort
of being a little more constrained in
what you do because you want the auto
scaling to work for you so that's a very
good environment for Java actually
because you don't have to think about
the scaling if you're working with
containers you know kuber Nettie's and
then running it on ji ke is obviously a
great environment for that this is
basically hosted Cooper Nettie so there
you kind of have more control you're
working with containers and you know
Cooper Nettie's like you can handle
especially if you're sort of breaking
your application up in on microservices
you can handle like pretty heavy pretty
heavy traffic and whatnot you can got to
do what you want there and then of
course you've got Google compute engine
or GCE and that's just a razve em so
obviously you can do what you want it's
just that all the setup is up to you so
there's lots of different places to run
Java workloads on Google's cloud
platform really depends on what you want
to do and I believe you can also run
like Java on some of that big data stuff
as well like data flow and some other
tools yeah that's correct actually
that's correct actually the data flow
the data flow SDKs actually a is
actually Java it's actually Java and so
yeah that's also really popular
excellent ray I know there's some other
places for Java supported not just to be
able to just run your code but other
things like that so like tooling and
SDKs and 90s and stuff ray you want to
talk a lil bit about stories so so
actually retrieve and another engineer
team lead here who's not here today on
the podcast but Patrick they actually
develop all the two wings for java so we
really good to me support for you know
if you're into the building tools so for
maven and Gradle we have plugins for
those for the Ides we also have these
integrations with eclipse IntelliJ so
the idea there is to for you to be able
to you know start a project and you know
deploy develop your applications and be
able to deploy into some of those
environments that the regime just
mentioned seamlessly directly from the
IDE but also if you need to integrate
with SE SEI CD platform of some sort or
manage your own deployment you can also
do that from the command line from your
plugins as well from the w tools and
yeah just to just adding on to that a
little bit so we've had in the past you
know plug-ins for clips like the Google
plugin for Eclipse which has been there
for a long time and is being used to
support a you know gwynt and actually
App Engine for a long time and we're
actually building new we've invested
back in that we're building new eclipse
tooling that is just purely cloud
focused actually so we putting a lot
more investment into Eclipse and will
want will expand that functionality as
well to handle things like data flow to
make it a lot easier to work with data
flow there already is a plugin for
Eclipse for data flow will integrate
those two together so it'll be in one
package so most I've been seeing a lot
of activity on the IntelliJ plug-in as
well you took a little bit of that as
well yeah yeah actually so that whole
thing started with um let's see so with
the with Android studio so Android
studio was released in i think it was
like 2013 and I it is built on the
IntelliJ platform as I think most people
know now and actually we did cloud
integration in there at like a while
back actually and the idea back then was
oh like create an app engine back end
and used Cloud endpoints to wire that up
to your mobile application with the
thought being that okay you just want a
simple back in and a way to talk to with
rest now we have other solutions like
firebase which are better suited to that
that's kind of what we started with and
then what we did was we basically spun
that back out and improved it into just
like a IntelliJ plugin for Community
Edition and ultimate to be able to just
like if you're just a cloud developer to
be able to work with
attention and that's kind of be our
basis we're going to expand upon that
and build more gcb features into that
plug-in and you know it's timely because
intelligence popularity has really taken
off like in the past two or three years
so like we really need to have a good
story in both ids because the
communities split across both of them
yeah I use IntelliJ what I don't
actually write each other in it he's
yeah I've got a race it's there it's
pretty good for for almost every
language it supports there they're very
good yeah cool so since we talked about
all the languages what about the other
languages that run on the JVM we've been
talking about Java but what if I have a
scalar application can I runs Calla on I
mean of course i can write a google
compute engine but can i run it also an
app engine yeah I can't take a stab at
it so for example with App Engine flex
you can basically run whatever you want
so it's not limited to you know pure
Java or any certain languages that you
know that the supports but if you really
want to you can definitely just writing
whatever languages you wish to writing
including any of the other JVM languages
and just being able to you know package
it up properly or even just package it
up into a docker container and as long
as you are listening to the right ports
and responding to the right health check
points and points we will be able to
serve those applications directly App
Engine flexible as a pass now of course
you can always if you have the container
you can also always just run leading a
Google container engine if you need fine
control over your application so you
could do either way come on what about
on standard is it a bit hacky I have to
ask them curious so if I want to take my
clothes your app and run it on a thin
gin standard can I do that now it
depends so this closure app actually
package you into a war file because you
need to be able to deploy that into a
tomcat server jetty container at the
moment so for example you cannot at the
moment run any of the jar files if you
have a self excludable jar but if you
can package up your app in a standard JD
container in a war file then you may be
able to run it
um you should give you a Trimark yeah
nah I'm taking for spin if you do enough
hackery there's probably some way to get
it going right yeah eventually there is
some way to get it going yeah and could
you share if there's any any actual
plans on doing more about these
languages like for instance we recently
had someone new in our team that gium
LaForge create he created groovy what
about groovy on a pentane standard I'm
talking about that's uh so uh that's a
good question actually um I think
they're so I mean there isn't anything
directly in the pipeline that I know
about to to support to support that but
I do know they're working to it sounds
kind of weird to make app engine stand
here environment slightly more flexible
you know so that so that you could
basically have less you're still running
java it's still your kind of in a JDM
but there's fewer restrictions so in a
world like that i could see more of that
being possible but I couldn't can creat
lycée yet honestly cool okay so I have a
question as some of you might know I
don't write Java that often i'm more of
a go person i know it's shocking so what
one of the things that I've heard about
is that you know like when you create
microservices in Java it's not really a
micro service because the JVM is so bad
is that actually a problem like if I'm
sincerely asking the questions like for
instance if you have on on ji ke is a
container going to take longer to start
because of the JVM being large or is
there any of those issues that people
that are writing Java so like you know
as far as Marco service is concerned
right the actual code that you write in
Java given the recent framework
developments like spring bootie and many
many others you actually write very few
code to achieve a lot because of other
common you know tasks that these
frameworks will be able to take care of
you for you and so the code that you
write is actually quite small you can
really focus on the business that you
to the business problem to solve in the
end the the end package the actual you
know binary file that you compile is
also very small so the JVM is really
there for you you know to support the
runtime environment now with docker
containers of course there's the concept
of layering so you can layer the JVM
image underneath of your app so that you
don't have to say redeploy hundreds of
megabytes elf JVM every single time so
the actual apt I'll you deploy could be
as small as the code that you actually
just changed and that is powerful
concept because now that will then give
you a very rapid deployment across you
know of the good of the service that you
have you don't have to really manage you
know which version of GV s you will be
running because of that will be
encapsulated in one of the image layers
are you depend on and the start time is
actually quite fast I mean these apps
can start in seconds to be honest so
that shouldn't be much of an issue guys
cool i'll not sick where I think you
mentioned spring their honor we've also
talked about jetty and a couple of
things like if I'm a Java developer and
I'm going back to a while and I used to
live a lot in the JVM in their
particular frameworks or as you're
talking about JD things like basically
runtime environments I guess that are
better supported than others like so if
i'm coming to gcp and i'm going to write
a Java rap should I be looking at
particular framework so particular
runtimes to get my app running so I can
run it on the web that makes sense so at
the very basic ave this you know the GE
standards with the servlet so that's
definitely supported right so even today
I mean since App Engine standard GE
spike has been supported in a way so you
can write a servlet you can serve your
JS piece a very standard Java stuff in
flex right you can run even more
basically removing some of the
traditional App Engine standard sandbox
restrictions you can run basically
whatever whatever framework framework
that you want to run but relief you want
to add to that um yeah so I think every
you covered it well I guess what I would
add is um there is a bunch of work that
that we that is in progress so it isn't
there yet because the to integrate more
of these frameworks with in
with gcp so for example in spring
there's things like sprint cloud stream
and we want to integrate that in with
our our cloud pub/sub right so that you
have a nice integration there you could
wire it up yourself if you wanted to but
that's obviously a bunch of work and we
want to have something like that ready
for you when you come to the platform
another example is um so we have the
stack driver diagnostics platform that's
part of its part of gcp so you know this
gives you information on your
application as it runs you know you like
mont you have stats you see like traces
and whatnot and and you see like you
know logging error reporting we want to
wire that into what spring also has in
that vein like spring actuator and
whatnot as well so that like basically
you can get that for free as opposed to
having to wire all of that up yourself
so these are these are integrations that
we're currently working on right now
they don't exist yet but we want to make
it a much better experience when you
come to our platform with spring and you
just get a lot more for free cool since
we're talking about stuff that's coming
is there anything else you want to talk
about that might be in the pipeline that
Java developers might be excited about
so one thing that I want mentioned is
something I should we just came out I
think before the new years it is our
Zipkin connector so if anyone who's
interested in developing microservices
in general a lot of it you might need to
be able to trace the calls across
multiple services and like in the Java
world a lot of it is using Zipkin and
you can tie it up with spring boot if
you want to so rather than maintaining
say your own Zipkin server there's
actually a proxy now that i can taking
Zipkin requests that's you know for the
tracing and then you can forward the
trace information directly into cloud
stock driver trace so what that means is
you have less than to maintain and you
don't have to change your code in order
to be able to trace your applications
you can browse all the trace information
directly from the gcp console another
another cool thing it isn't it isn't
super new but I don't know how
well-known it is is the cloud debugger
actually so this is a pretty cool piece
of technology um it's actually a what
you might call like a postmortem
debugger or
option debugger so you know it you when
you set a breakpoint you're not actually
stopping execution what you're actually
doing is you're saying that okay you
want to take a sample or trace of like
some other requests and the sort of a
snapshot of the stack at that point in
time so that you can come back later and
you can sort of you like okay you know
when I hit this I hit this breakpoint
what was going on at this time this is
pretty cool because normally you can't
use this type of feature in production
because you would halt execution and
then no one could go to your site and
that's no good right but what we've done
here is now like you know you can even
set conditional breakpoints so like on a
certain condition you trip this and then
you can be like oh what happened here
like this was hit like why was it hit
let me walk through and we've actually
wired integration into IntelliJ so you
can actually walk through the stack and
look at the stuff as you would just in a
normal debugger so you're not actually
breaking execution but at least you have
a familiar interface into that and they
recently added a new feature I think
it's in the web UI we haven't into the
IDE yet which is called like dynamic log
points so you know how many times you
had like where your you know your you
want to know more information because
something's going wrong in production
and you're like oh geez I wish I had
added that log statement and then you go
you have the logs team you rebuild you
whatever you redeploy hours go by and
then you see the log in you're like oh
wow I wish I had even more login for if
you do that again right with dynamic
logs you actually can set at a point in
the code that's in production on a
source line and say like I want to print
this this information these variables
and actually it actually sets that
dynamically like in the bytecode so
without having to redeploy or anything
you actually can set a logging statement
in there and you'll start seeing the
logging statements as their hit so
that's like a really powerful feature to
sort of like figure out what's going on
production without like and saving you
probably like ours or I don't know days
of like redeploying with like more logs
and more logs and more logs so that's a
really cool feature yeah as I go for
that makes me super jealous one day I'm
day one day you guys get there so I feel
like we should definitely uh you know
take a stab or take a look at the
elephant in the room
java 8 I believe that's what states that
in how's that going java that's a good
question very good quote so um so Java 8
actually works quite well on average and
flex if you're the App Engine flex
environment we have supported runtimes
for java 8 or openjdk like eight and
plus jetty nine or just open jdk 8 and
obviously you're like what are you doing
on standard why isn't it there and
you're right well that's actually in the
pipeline like we can't promise an exact
date yet but it's actually being worked
on and you know like it's looking very
promising so this is something that's
top of mind for us cool so just what do
I have 11 funny thing when you said the
other phone in the room I thought about
Hadoop so different different elephant
yeah a lot of illness yeah I guess we're
kind of running out of time but is there
any other topic that you like to discuss
something that we may have missed right
no I think I'm okay here but uh oh one
thing France asked what are you going to
try Java again she's wondering uh when
in what when it has support for go
because all the Java routines if you
want to you get you can have goroutines
in alternative JVM languages in
alternatively actually actually I'm
thinking about learning closures oh yeah
it's like Java Jack better just kidding
I I'm not a troll yeah we're good we're
basically gonna keep investing in job as
much as we can until you switch over to
Java so you know we were steam ahead
gonna get you off go you know what and
that's an incentive for you never to
touch java so right always get every
morning hard overshoot yeah I am an
important part of the java community by
not being parted exactly exactly what
about you achieve is there any topic
that you like no I think we um I think
we covered everything pretty well this
was great I guess all i would add to it
is that yeah like we're really serious
about java and we're putting a lot of
resources investment behind it because
there's just so much we can do to make
it better for for java developers on gcp
there's just tons we can do so we're
putting a lot of attention there
excellent and i know either one or both
of you are you can be at particular
events coming up as well yep so I do try
to
um you know go to a plenty of Java
related events and Java user groups so
I'm gonna be traveling quite a bit
around you know one of the first stop is
gonna be J focus in Sweden in February
so I'm looking forward to that and you
know if you do see me on the road or if
you want to chat I would love to you
know learn about you know your
experiences and how you want to use the
platform and you know provide any of the
feedback to us love to get it also back
to the engineering teams as well to make
our experience better and so that
developers will love to use and right
after that I think we're gonna meet at
[ __ ] yeah I was here Foster no actually
if Austin comes before that some gum
being fosston for the weekend and then
go straight to Sweden right after that
you know and there's also the devoxx us
that's gonna be their first day box in
the United States so I'm gonna be there
with many many other people as well
including Liam La Forge and many of the
engineers will not be there so looking
forward to meeting everyone it devoxx us
too yeah very cool excellent well to
both you thank you so much for joining
us it has been a pleasure n to delight
talking to both of you thank you it was
great thanks so much so thanks again to
Ray and reche for taking the time and
making me discovered that actually Java
is a very interesting language with a
vibrant community yeah now it was a
really good interview obviously Java is
very much alive and well now yeah that's
for sure yeah i sees the JVM a lot so
it's it's a warm spot in my heart for it
and so it's great to see all the stuff
that's going on there I like to talk
about it but I know it is a very
interesting language because you know
like this is basically half of a content
that is built on it so it's good to have
it and and have a good place to run it
like Google claw perform anyway I think
it's time to go with our question of the
week so we had a really interesting
question this week I think in terms of
say you have a whole bunch of data on
amazon s3 for example and you want to
transfer data to Google Cloud Storage is
there an easy way of doing that for an
interesting question but I actually have
a pre pre question for that which is
do you know what s 3 S stands for I do
not know what s 3 cents for what is s 3
stand for I'm almost sure it's simple
storage service but I'm not going to be
sure but i think so which would you know
it's kind of a cool name but yeah
everybody calls it s 3 and then it's
like what anyway so yeah how do you
transform it from a WS s 3 how do you
move that data to to Google class
storage I actually do not know so it is
interesting so the gsl so we do have a
GSU till command line tool for working
with cloud storage you can use the GSU
till GSU till utility that sounds weird
the GSU till tool to work with Amazon s3
buckets as well however ah the probably
the most efficient way of doing things
is we do have this thing called a cloud
storage transfer service which is
specifically set up for transferring
data from one cloud storage provider to
another which is kind of cool obviously
you're going to have network network
costs for moving from one together so
that keep that in mind but you're able
to set it up so that you have like
basically sources and sinks so like
where do you want to go from where do
you want it to go to and then you can
kind of set it up to happen like
periodically or maybe just once off
there's a programmatic interface there's
you can go through the console you I you
know and there's a series of rest api
eyes as well so you can really kind of
pick and choose how you want it to to
work but it is a nice and easy way of
just transferring that data across if
you need to do that between different
cloud providers cool that sounds that
sounds indeed very useful I don't know
how often that kind of things are needed
to be done but if you think about
starting to try a real club platform and
you know it's like you need to pass all
your data around just probably the best
way to do it yeah and i think you know
it's kind of cool it's one of those
things that you really need it when you
need it but if you don't need it then
you don't like its whether it's fun or
other yeah but if you if you don't know
it exists and it's it could be really
painful to pull everything down say
locally like veggie skew tell and then
push it back up again into the cloud
whereas you much rather run it over the
big fat pipes that usually run between
all up again and if you need to do
sinking in between AWS and disappear I
think that there is a thing that I
should my
because you know it's a tool raining go
and it's open source it's called me neo
and they're really cool because you know
they're they're reading go so of course
a good is that cool tool but check it
out it actually supports a bunch of
different services storage services from
different clouds so they're interesting
s3 but also there's Google Cloud storage
they have their own meaning server it
also supports OpenStack Swift so it's
definitely worth having a look if what
you need is a little bit more complex
than just passing from one side to the
other ones excellent well Francis before
we run off today I think we should
remind people how to get in contact with
us so they can send us emails and cool
things of the weeks and questions the
week and all sorts of other good stuff
yes because we haven't done that yet I
in 2017 so you say the things I say the
places okay so we'll start with okay if
they want to go to our domain name where
can I go that is TCP podcast com or Club
google com / podcast if they want to
email us where should they do that they
should send an email to hello GC
podcaster come if they want to find us
on reddit it is our / DC podcast if i
want to find us on google+ plus cheesy
podcast and if they want to find us on
twitter at GC podcast at last at least
there's a finger going on there's a name
definitely a theme and finally if they
want to find us on slack where can they
find us oh that is the hard one on slack
there's a pop cast channel inside of the
Google cloud platform community that you
can join by getting somewhere bit ly /
GCPD dash slack cool we'll have all of
those just in case people are wondering
they're all in the web page anyway so
just go to get out of Jesus podcast com
okay so before we go I guess it's time
to ask what are you going to be next
week actually what are you now you're in
san francisco i'm in barcelona what are
your plans afterwards so i'll be at GDC
the game developer conference here in
san francisco we're sponsoring a bunch
of events going on so we are sponsoring
women in games if anyone's going to be
at that party will be there
we're sponsoring blackston games as well
so everyone's going to be there come and
say hello we'll be around I think if
you're looking for us we'll definitely
be hanging out by the improbable booth
because their partner of ours and they
we have a developer day there's Google
developer day on Tuesday and a sponsored
session i'll be there talking about
basically running dedicated game servers
in the cloud mainly on communities
actually both in my lightning talk and
in our sponsored session on wednesday
morning as well and then they'll be next
yes cloud next that's going to be fun
that sounds like a lot of things going
on for you but sounds for ya so parties
it's all around GDC yeah very cool it's
gonna be crazy I know you're up to a
bunch of stuff well you're wandering
around Europe yes I'm actually kind of
doing a European tour because you know I
like to I like cold weather i'm
currently in barcelona because i will be
speaking at the go meet up on thursday
so tomorrow and then the week after that
I will be in Paris where I'm trying to
organize also made up but it's not
completely sure but that weekend will be
in fosston in Brussels and we have a go
devrim so you get your view around come
say hi I think we still have time we
still have plays for lightning talk so
if there's anyone around there visiting
they want to give a lining talk about go
let me know and after that yeah be
coming back for go SF we're gonna
celebrate that go one that ate is coming
out and then week after that go for
Cohen India so yeah it's traveling a
little bit around the world and that is
before club mix so it's kind of crazy
yeah yeah I'm you're presenting cloud
next as well yes I am presenting our
cloud next I'm going to be talking about
Google Cloud endpoints very cool i'll be
on stage as well talking with our gaming
partner probable about massively large
persistent online worlds that sounds
that sounds very interesting that sounds
kind of like a little bit like pokemon
go missive lee online worlds yeah this
is more in the MMO kind of realm very
large online simulations that sounds
pretty cool very interesting stuff
actually it is pretty cool awesome
France esque thank you very much for
joining me yet again this week thank you
so much mark for waking up so early and
thank you all for listening yeah and
talk to you all next week
[Music]
you
[Music]